you should have changed the textview
into a ListView element then you can
remove this text attribute because you
don't need it anymore
now from the UX mocs you'll remember
that the list takes up the whole screen
so we want to set the width and height
to be match parent that will make the
ListView match the dimensions of its
parent which is this relative layout and
to find out the parent of this relative
layout it's actually in this activity
main.xml file because the fragment is
contained within the activity within
this file we see that this view is also
matched parent for height and width so
now we can confirm that the ListView
actually will take up the full screen
going back to the fragment main file we
can add the ID ListView forecasts onto
the ListView and then since this layout
only contains one child we can simplify
the layout by changing this into a frame
layout